The communication internet is,
is something that's ubiquitous and we're
using it 24 hours a day.
All of us have our cell phones and our
desktop computers and we're generating
information in the form of audio,
video and text.
And we're sharing it with friends,
were sharing it with the world in a,
in a communication network that's
designed to be distributed,
collaborative and that favors peer to
peer production.
Now that Communication Internet is
converging with this very nascent energy
internet where we're now able to
generate our own green electricity,
distributed collaborative peer to peer
and share it with the help of the
communication internet,
we create an energy internet,
a transmission lines become an internet.
And now the third component,
we are just beginning to see the first
glimpse of an automated transport and
logistics internet and then the whole
package is complete.
Right now,
logistics is a pretty inefficient
business.
Uh,
if you take a look across the United
States,
like other countries,
and you look at a truck on the road,
sometimes those trucks are empty,
they're deadheading back,
they'd taken their cargo and then
there's nothing on the trip back.
Or they only have 20 or 30% of that
truck filled.
Right now,
our logistics system is not coordinated
into a network.
There are thousands of warehouses and
distribution centers,
but every company usually has only five
or 10 of these warehouses somewhere in
the country.
So they have to take their,
their trains are the trucks all the way
to where they're a handful of centers
are.
But what would happen if all the
thousands of warehouses and distribution
centers,
privately owned,
came together in a cooperative network.
So if you're a general electric or
Walmart or wherever,
or a PR,
a small prosumer,
a small and medium sized company,
you would have access to any one of
those warehouses when they have surplus
space and you could move your transport
only where you needed it in real time
instead of going to a few centralized
warehouses across 3000 miles.
But to do that,
you'd have to have common protocols
where everything is standardized so you
could get your packages through in the
same containers with radio recognition
technology like federal express as so
you know where you're,
you're afraid is in your package at any
given moment on the supply chain.
And then we're now starting to move
toward a driverless vehicles.
There'll be in mass production within
five to 10 years everywhere according to
the six major auto companies.
And so we'll be able to have a transport
system where we power our vehicles from
energy from our energy internet and will
power our electric vehicles and fuel
cell cars,
trucks and buses powered by hydrogen,
all of that from our energy internet at
near zero marginal cost transport that's
already here in parts of Europe.
We now have electric vehicles,
fuel cell vehicles powered with energy
that's near zero marginal costs.
In a few years there'll be driverless
reducing the cost even further.
And so this transport and logistics
internet is connecting with the energy
internet and the communication internet,
which provides the data one system.
It is a game changer.
It is one of the great technology
revolutions in history.
It's going to change our entire way of
life.
Every single person.
What it mainly means is it's the
democratization of everything.
This means that millions of people and
soon billions of people,
they're not going to have to rely on the
goodwill of a handful of globally
integrated,
large,
vertically integrated companies for the
main stuff of life.
We've now freed ourselves with
information to zero or near zero
marginal cost.
Millions of us are producing and sharing
with each other,
and we now have the first early adopters
that are now producing their own green
electricity at near zero marginal costs,
millions of them already,
and we've just starting to see a
transport and logistics internet that
could get us to near zero marginal cost.
This is the democratization of
everything and it's going to change the
economic model.